it's like in Mario when we make a really
hard job and you're like oh the rest of
this level just gets harder this is my
first time like cooking with all these
cameras and these fancy lights these
microphones like I'm not gonna lie I'm
scared alright and now we scrape
bring on the bad chicken baby what is in
that song I called a bunch of cheese
shops I know I'm looking for hundred hi
god I'm gonna have croissants never gets
easier
well this is awkward yeah I'm like a
gentle sweet just by the end of the day
me and that's cheesecake should be
looking like this
what pash looks pretty much like an
Olive Garden breadsticks I just wanted
to look sexy okay oh yeah oh so pretty
oh gosh
furgus we've made some adjustments it's
so correct oh we got a double yolk I
just had a double yolk good luck right
okay there's nothing wrong with a little
extra cheese but kind of the way I try
to live my life beautiful mess the
sausage is I thought next level what is
in that sauce
[Music]
the hell oh my god if you talk to your
food and encourage it it's more likely
to do what you want
protip I think we've been insane for a
very long time and this is kind of like
the peak of insanity great we're getting
somewhere
I trust my this is a craziest thing I've
ever done in my life besides meeting a
Spice Girl it can help make stiffer
Peaks
[Music]
you got the texture right yeah I don't
think I did you'd be creamier why are
you not cooperating today what do you
want from us it takes the bite whoa
for real take leave it leave it out take
it off the fork oh yes
[Music]